just do it differently per girl the
sports apparel giant teamed up with the
Japanese fashion label Sakai for an
eight-piece nike lab sekai capsule
collection writer megan Wiggins said in
a piece for slate nike called it a bold
expression of femininity in reality it's
comical and insulting to female athletes
everywhere okay so we're going to link
to the article with this down below and
you'll be able to see some more pictures
if you want when I first saw the article
and I saw what you're seeing there in
the video I thought it was a joke like I
actually thought it was a joke I know
many guys that are athletes I know many
girls that are athletes I get it girls
things have to be cut slightly
differently for their bodies alia made
the hips are a little different you know
the shoes baby could be a little I'm a
gas you don't like it when you're
driving the lane with a spot you don't
like a nice cape okay about Slama JAMA
you know I locate flutter you know it's
funny that my partner odd my first
thought was picturing myself like
jumping in a cape swoop but really like
this seems so ridiculous because
athletics are like the great equalizer
and it's up to you and you know your
abilities and now girls have to be
girlier I know it's so confusing I
thought it was I'm like okay it's an art
piece it's like Yoko Ono it started
designing is something interesting like
that right in a museum like oh this is
some sort of weird idea of this okay oh
they're serious they really want me to
wear a skirt and a cape while I'm yeah
like the Wardrobe the Wardrobe art
director from a bad 1980's movie oh yeah
Anakin seven it is I'm horrible what are
they smoking there so is this just all
week so I guess the other part maybe is
that this is just like fashion week when
they just like no like Haute Couture
right and they Danity yeah and no one's
gonna wear any of this stuff I gotta say
I was all about it at this one you know
you cut the whopper scented perfume for
the banaan story of the nike women's
wear I mean wait salsa firefight we were
gonna do a story about a whopper scented
perfume but we think it might be an
oncoming April Fool's joke we'll find
out soon enough did you uh now crush
that's not we thought we thought it was
real big about my legal escape and did
play hoops by myself now I just I just
think it's one of those
is one those things where you know
Serena it's a double standard to Serena
Williams who likes to design is it
Serena or Venus that does the I think
it's arena yeah she said designs cuz if
she would have done something like this
to be a part of couture fashion week
right it would have been Harold as this
great thing but because it's kind of
goofy looking and like bad a tease you
know version of the future movie that
would happen in 2017 right you know
we're often you know women are being
down trotted and you know look I I I was
raised by women I have women children
I've been married to a woman you know
I'm Pro you've got all of this stuff
it's are commemorating 60 I got a lot of
women around me all that one right here
and I'm totally pro women but this is
like we're gonna get riled over some
eight pieces of clothing yeah yeah
denigrating women little it exactly yeah
yeah it's one of those outrage that's
like let's distract ourselves for 30
seconds um but yeah really if Nikes
serious about this day I don't fit I
mean what's that line for me it isn't
April for maybe this is maybe this is
the April Fool what's the line from the
incredibles movie with a little edna
mold like okay okay all right we
exercise our outrage on this one are you
upset at Nike let us know in the
comments right now